[موسيقى]
المنتخب المصري نحى نتيجه التعادل المخيب
امام موزمبيق في المباراه الافتتاحيه
جانبا استعدادا لمواجهه واعده مع غانا
وحسب التقارير صحفيه سيجري البرتغالي روي
فيتوريا بعض التعديلات على التشكيله التي
لعبت المباراه الافتتاحيه ومن ابرزها
ادخال احمد فتوح بديلا لمحمد حمدي وعمر
كمال عبد الواحد على حسابه محمد هاني
اضافه لاعاده صلاح الى مركزه المفضل في
الجناح الايسر اما منتخب النجوم السوداء
فلا يختلف حاله عن مصر اذ سيرفع شعار
الفوز بعد الخساره المفاجئه امام منتخب
الراس الاخضر في المباراه
الاولى ودائما ما تشهد لقاءات المنتخبين
تنافسا قويا اذ تواجه في 22 مباراه حقق
الفراعنه الفوز في عشر منها وفازت غانا في
ست منها وتعادل في ست مناسبات المنتخبان
سبق لهما التتويج بلقب المسابقه القارات
طوج مصر بسبعه القاب مقابل اربعه
[موسيقى]
لغان